bonjour à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans ce nouveau numéro de ski mag
c'est officiel les jeux olympiques de
mes 24 se dérouleront à paris et
certaines épreuves se tiendront ici même
à saint quentin en yvelines
avant cela à l'agglomération recevra une
autre compétition prestigieuse pour la
rentrée 2018 la ryder cup de golf alors
de tels événements ne s'improvise pas
comment le territoire s'organise type
quelles peuvent être les retombées
sportives économiques et la notoriété
pour l'agglomération ont fait lé point
c'est bart
[Musique]
les jeux olympiques 2024 dans la
capitale paris en rêvait le 6 ou la fait
que c'est un événement exceptionnel
une vraie satisfaction tout le monde est
ravi pour moi c'était un immense bonheur
c'est une très très grande satisfaction
pour cette fois ci ça se termine de biya
[Applaudissements]
oui cette fois ci c'est la bonne exit
les chèques de 2012 le 13 septembre
dernier pari devenait officiellement la
ville d'accueil des jeux olympiques de
2024 et dans la foulée saint quentin en
yvelines en profite puisque certaines
épreuves se dérouleront sur le
territoire
[Musique]
le 13 septembre le vélodrome recevait
près de 800 élèves et collégiens saint
quentinois venus fêter le sport cyclisme
golf tennis boxe judo
ce jour là le vélodrome s'était
transformée en site olympique
en attendant depuis lima annonce
officielle du choix de paris par le
comité international olympique
[Musique]
l'agglomération de 50 ans delvin investi
depuis longtemps dans le sport nous
avons organisé déjà les championnats du
monde les championnats d'europe et bien
sûr quand paris est repartie pour une
candidature pour 2024 et bien sûr
cinquantaine étaient présentes puisque
nous avions le golf le vélodrome le
stade de bmx et aussi la colline des
lampes ou pour l'ordination du vtt et je
pense que c'est une récompense bien sûr
pour les élus de 50 des ports toute la
population et bien sûr aussi
il récompense pour nos jeunes qui auront
quand même là des perspectives
extraordinaires comme il y en aura pas
d'autres en france
et l'instant flash mob pour clore la
journée
[Musique]
nous avons eu la la génération 2024 nous
avons des jeunes qui sont enthousiasmés
d'accueillir les jeux olympiques des
jeunes qui vont s'intéresser au sport et
donc il nous faut faciliter cette chose
là et c'est un élan qui doit être donnée
car lors de ces jeux olympiques
pas moins de six épreuves se dérouleront
sur les territoires saint quentinois
nous avons le vélodrome derrière nous et
effectivement ce sont des épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste qui vont se dérouler
dans ce vélodrome un équipement
extraordinaire un équipement national
extraordinaire et puis également
l'épreuve des scream du pentathlon
moderne se déroulera également au sein
de ce vélodrome sur leur central à
vélodrome qui à l'origine avait été
conçu pour les jo de 2012 finalement
obtenu par monde mais je vont se passer
dans notre jardin dans notre maison ici
au vélodrome nationale voilà c'est la
piste où on s'entraîne deux fois par
jour de dire qu'il va y avoir trois
mille personnes
dans les gradins et des gens pour nous
en faire encourager les français
voilà je pense que ça sera un moment
particulier à vivre je pense que ça va
faire bouger beaucoup de choses aussi
avec la fédération française de cyclisme
on va être vraiment tiré vers le haut
les espoirs c'est bien évidemment que la
france brille on actuellement cinq
disciplines au programme des jeux
olympiques on en avait quatre sur les
deux dernières olympiades
il ya une cinquième qui nous a qui a
rejoint le cyclisme c'est le bmx
freestyle et donc le cyclisme a
énormément de chances de
les imite donc l'épreuve aura lieu sur
l'île de loisirs une piste sera créée
par le cio le temps de la manifestation
les courses de vtt aime se dérouleront
sur la colline d'elancourt point
culminant de l'île de france avec ses
230 m la colline et le courtoise sera
aménagée d'ici sept ans pour les
sportifs n'est pas seulement un parc
famille est d'ores et déjà prévue
parcours pédestre accrobranche ainsi
qu'une multitude d'activités devrait
être pérennisé au delà des jo les
infrastructures en plus c'est vrai qu'on
va être très très très garni sûr sûr sûr
les abîmes puisqu'on va avoir beaucoup
d'épreuves de vélo plus le bas tapis
modernes et peut-être de l'équitation
aussi sur sur versailles
nous aurons probablement sur le
territoire le passage également de
l'épreuve de cyclisme sur route puisque
nous avons lavés lecture rose à ses
voisines des halles en château de
versailles à ses voisins également et
donc nous avons probablement ce passage
est là ce sera un spectacle gratuit pour
tout le monde donc je pense que ça va ça
va permettre à beaucoup de gens de
participer à la fête à moindre coût et
puis n'oublions pas le golf national le
golf national qui accueillera les
épreuves de golf pour ces jeux
olympiques 2024 2024 cédant 7 ans c'est
demain les élus et organisateurs sont
déjà à pied d'oeuvre pour mettre toutes
les infrastructures en place y compris
au niveau des transports
d'autant que le projet de la ligne 18
prévus pour être prolongée jusqu'à saint
quentin en yvelines d'ici à 2024 semble
remis en question il ya des rumeurs
inquiétantes
effectivement sur la mise en suspens sur
la mise en sommeil de cette prolongation
de la ligne 18 entre
or que le plateau de saclay et puis
versailles et donc c'est une chose qui
n'est pas envisageable nous avons obtenu
les jeux olympiques et dont nous avons
maintenant l'événement qui doit arriver
il n'est pas envisageable d'arrêter
cette cette infrastructure
maintenant c'est attendu par les
entreprises c'est attendu par toutes les
personnes qui se déplacent
quotidiennement et il nous faut
impérativement cette ligne de 18 pour
véritablement que en 2024
on puisse bénéficier je dirais de ses
moyens de déplacement pour accroître et
favoriser ou bien évidemment l'accueil
de toutes les délégations étrangères qui
viendront sur notre territoire
un bonheur n'arrive jamais seul saint
quentin en yvelines accueillera dans
moins d'un an
l'un des plus gros événement sportif de
la planète la ryder cup de golf
la première ryder cup française se
tiendra sur le parcours de l'albatros du
golf national
[Musique]
là aussi c'est un événement
extraordinaire jamais eu lieu en france
et c'est une chance inouïe quand on a su
que finalement on allait la voir
c'était génial pour cette compétition
qu'en tête a porté sur quelque chose
pour nos jeunes ou et est donc forcément
ça fera progresser le golf français
d'une manière générale et on n'a pas le
droit de se planter en septembre 2010 8
24 des meilleurs joueurs mondiaux seront
sur le parcours de l'albatros du golf
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines la
compétition bisannuelle entre européens
et américains est une première en france
sur la première fois finalement clown
ryder cup sort des îles britanniques au
du territoire américain en fait donc
c'est une réelle chance pour nous
d'avoir cet événement qui est le
troisième événement sportif le plus
suivi au monde après les jeux olympiques
et la coupe du monde de foot depuis 2015
un vaste programme de travaux a été
lancé plus de sept millions d'euros ont
été investis aux abords du golf national
pour les vestiaires à l'accueil et dans
la boutique afin d'égaler les standards
internationaux
la ryder cup ce spécial chaque bol des
différents elle est plus beau sans ceux
qui accueillent le meilleur pour moi sur
le site
trois parcours loiselet un parcours de
neuf trous
l'aigle 18 trous puis l'albatros sur
lequel les joueurs du monde entier
viendront concourir en septembre 2018 et
même quelques français alors j'espère
qu'un aura je pense qu'on a tout à fait
le potentiel pour qu'un oeil à alexander
levy je pense que la plus grande chance
il ya du bruit sont aussi bien sûr les
joueurs sont motivés là processus de
qualification est en route mais on a
d'excellents espoir parce qu'on a des
résultats en septembre et octobre du
joueur français qui sont excellents
romans va t-elle notamment est la plus
récemment dimanche victor dubuisson le
golfe lui devrait rayonner sur tout le
territoire
en tout le monde doit tirer bénéfice de
la ryder cup
quelqu'un qui voyage des etats-unis de
fines ou d'angleterre même il va pas
venir jusqu'au golf national pour jouer
un parcours il va rester trois quatre
jours il va aller jouer ailleurs
il y à une création d'activité de
richesse même pour les engueuler photos
et les autres golf c'est tout d'abord le
blue green de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
créé il ya trente ans ce golf propose
deux parcours de 18 trous est ainsi tout
réservé à l'enseignement 250 personnes
ont choisi cette dernière formule en
plus des 700 abonnés habituel situé à
trappes solide de loisirs le blue green
élargit son offre aux non abonnés ce qui
permet de découvrir le golf lors d'un
one shot
plus au nord le golf isabella et
familiale ce golf attend avec impatience
la grande compétition
elle va avoir lieu tout près du bella
bella à 25 km et donc la communauté
urbaine de saint quentin 3 offre
complète de compétition commerciale et
associatives privé plus familial qu'elle
golf d'isabela donc c'est une chance
pour les golfeurs en france mais une
chance aussi pour isabela de s'insérer
dans un très beau programme
le territoire de tous les golfs et de
tous les publics paulienne hermitage
rappelle qu'une inscription annuelle au
golf national représente 600 euros par
an soit moins cher que l'inscription
dans une salle de fitness une
inscription qui sera le seul moyen de
découvrir ce sport car les places pour
la compétition ont été vendus en moins
de 50 minutes en septembre dernier
en attendant c'est l'excitation de la
tente les jamais assisté à un driver cup
mais j'ai assisté à l'équivalent féminin
qui s'appelle la solheim cup et l'
ambiance
unique et quand je me dis que la ryder
cup c'est dix fois plus important je me
dis on travaille on reste concentré et
en attendant le jour j avec impatience
mais c'est comme un mariage la journée
de mariage ça passe tellement vite ça va
ça va passer à une vitesse folle
de son côté le territoire s'organisent
pour accueillir les 65 mille visiteurs
quotidiens qui seront présents sur
l'agglomération durant la dizaine de
jours que durera la compétition
il nous faut créer des infrastructures
des gares routières
il nous faut effectivement des navettes
en nombre à partir de massy à partir
d'autres sites pour permettre d'amener
les spectateurs mais d'éviter des
parkings à toute proximité du golfe
le tout en veillant à la tranquillité
des habitants et des entreprises et à la
sécurité des lieux et de la
manifestation une manifestation dont les
retombées sont multiples la première
attente c'est bien évidemment des
retombées économiques
l'apport de ces événements créer un
engouement pour notre territoire qui est
des leurs qui est déjà largement équipés
en très belle
l'entreprise mais on sait que d'autres
sont sur le point de nous rejoindre
et puis il ya tout un secteur qui est
aussi attentif à cela c'est celui du
commerce
un commerce qui connaît déjà une
certaine affluence l'hôtel ibis situé
tout près du vélodrome enregistre déjà
depuis quelques mois les premières
réservations en vue de la ryder cup mais
visiteurs français et anglais sont les
premiers à réserver leur place
autre retombée celle de la notoriété
leur idole pop c'est 500 millions de
téléspectateurs les jeux olympiques
c'est encore davantage ces trois
milliards et demi de téléspectateurs
c'est dire que pendant tout le temps de
ses compétitions
saint quentin en yvelines va être mis à
l'honneur sur l'ensemble de la planète
l'esprit golfique a déjà pris le pas sur
le territoire d'ici à la compétition en
septembre 2018
de nombreuses animations devraient se
dérouler pour sensibiliser les plus
jeunes
le 4 octobre dernier l'union nationale
du sport scolaire des yvelines
regroupait près de 800 collégiens du
département sur l'île de loisirs pour la
dixième édition du raid des collégiens
au programme golf
du golfe certes mais pas seulement car
l'esprit olympique souffle également sur
saint quentin en yvelines
alors ce jour là il y avait aussi de la
course à pied et d'utile et certaines
valeurs chères aux sportifs la
sensibilisation à l'environnement à la
nutrition et au handisport
c'est ce qui est important c'est que la
jeunesse s'empare de ces événements
car c'est l'avenir et c'est eux qui vont
importer stablement poursuivre ce que
les aînés ont déjà engagé mais il reste
encore des choses magnifiques à faire
sur le territoire de 50 ha et toutes ces
belles manifestations y contribueront ce
qui est dingue c'est terminé pour cette
fois à très bientôt pour de nouvelles
aventures saint-quentinoise ciao
[Musique]